across the rust belt abandoned coal
mines are leaching toxins into rivers
and streams
turning them shades of dirty red
the color is disturbing but for two men
it's also the tint of inspiration
one is a civil engineer
with plans to extract these toxins from
the waters
the other is a painter
who transforms that material into
acrylic paints and stunning works of art
this part of southeastern ohio is
considered appalachia and we have a
strong relationship with the ohio river
we have a strong relationship with all
of the environmental destruction that's
happened here
the abandoned mines have irretrievably
altered the watershed discharging acidic
water into nearby streams and rivers due
to a process known as acid mine drainage
so just in ohio there's more than 1 300
stream miles that are impacted by acid
mine drainage the mine that discharges
here at this specific treatment site
it's been abandoned for probably about
100 years
fish and other aquatic life is really
sensitive to ph and the streams get
coated with this iron sludge
this is the mine that we call the back
gate mine seep and it has been pumping
out acid mine drainage for the last
hundred years now the toxic discharge at
bat gate is the result of an abandoned
improperly sealed coal mine it delivers
about 4 000 pounds of iron every day
into this one stream nearby that's like
junking two cars into the stream every
day
what i'm doing in my research right now
is trying to come up with a way to clean
up streams in southeast ohio so through
our research we've discovered that when
we remove iron from the acid mine
drainage we can precipitate it and
settle it as a pigment and i realize
that by producing pigment i could pay
for this whole process
when i got to the dry pigment
i realized that i i didn't have the
skills to figure out what made a good
pigment and what made a bad pigment
i basically was knocking on doors in the
art department to see if i could find
anyone to help me and that's when i ran
into john i was like could you tell me
if this was a good paint or not
and we sat down and he said very
scientific jargon well the pigment needs
to be this and it needs to be then and i
was like yeah i can do that but what we
really need to do is make something that
visually is compelling we need people to
look at this and go what
what are you doing that's crazy and get
on board
[Music]
one of the things that i really liked
about getting the pigment from these
acid mine seeps is that it has
characteristics of the place where you
get it from
so from guy i would come back and say
well this is too orange i want it to be
a deeper red because it's more valuable
for these reasons once i get the pigment
from the lab i put it onto a tempered
glass table i'll add an oil dispersant
for there which basically makes the
pigment want to stick to things so it
wants to become a good paint and then
that can be scraped up into jars or
tubes and you can use oil paint for
years and years and years and years
he makes these connections between
nature and pollution and science
and he puts that in in this something
that is beautiful to see
we've had recent interest from gambling
artist colors in portland
and we are producing a custom batch of
the color 500 tubes of oil paint with
our name on it
the proceeds from selling the pigment
will pay for the plant it will pay for
employees they'll pay for the cleanup of
a stream
the moment that the plant becomes viable
that is the moment that the stream goes
back to biological viability
it's not a 10-year thing it's not a
20-year thing it's not a 50-year thing
it's a tomorrow kind of thing
artists are not people who create from
themselves but they actually serve a
role
as communicators for the divine in the
universe i'm always thinking about these
colors and how they relate to
where it came from
thanks to the team's efforts in
september of 2016 john was invited to
exhibit his art at the united nations in
new york city i'm very lucky to be
invited to have a show at the united
nations headquarters and what i'm really
hoping to do is to form even more
collaborations with people in many
places around the world where we're all
working towards this goal of a more
sustainable planet
[Music]
you